Yeah.
Okay.
Welcome back to human emotion.
Today we'll continue to
focus our discussion on the
elicitation of emotion by
learning about all the exciting and
really cool tools and methods that one can
use to both understand
and quantify emotion.
So think of yourself as a laboratory
scientist trying to probe the mysteries of
emotion.
Okay,
this will be our second part in this
exciting module focused on how do we
trigger emotions and once we trigger them,
how do we measure them in the first place?
In other words,
we're really trying to get at the
question of what makes us emotional.
So today we'll continue our discussion
of the different tools and methods that
researchers use to elicit emotion.
And then we'll conclude with our takeaway
questions and another fantastic expert
interview in this field.
So let's jump right in with the second
part of the tools and methods that are
the coolest things.
As a scientist,
when you get into how do
you trigger an emotion,
how do you get people to feel emotional?
So you might remember these three core
processes we talked about in our last
lecture, including emotion,
reactivity, emotion regulation,
and emotion understanding.
So again,
these are the three big processes that
we try to get at as researchers when
we're developing tools
to tap into emotion.
So these were the eight domains
of emotional dissertation tools.
We talked about the top four in our
last lecture. And as you can see here,
highlighted in the lovely color red.
We're going to be talking about these
four bad boys here at the bottom.
So we'll start talking about music and
singing, the acoustic startle reflex,
startle, eyeblink modulation,
and the directed facial
action task. So let's begin.
What might be perhaps the most intriguing
to all of you now music and singing.
So how do we use this to elicit emotion?
So we all know that music
elicits strong feelings, right?
Some of us feel the most emotional when
we listened to our favorite song or song
that reminds us of a really
important time in our life.
So researchers have tried to leverage
this everyday experience to use music as a
way of getting people into
a certain emotional state.
So one approach that's used by Eric Eich
has been to bring people into the lab
and have them listen to different
kinds of classical music.
And he's had them listen to classical
music that's used to elicit both happy
feelings and sad feelings.
Okay?
So by using these tools,
he's found that people can actually
get them into the emotional states.
Now what about singing? This is
intimately tied to music, right?
And when we think about singing, how
can they use singing to elicit emotions?
So the way that my lab has approached
this is by using singing to try to elicit
self conscious emotions. So perhaps we've
all had our fair share of, you know,
embarrassing Karaoke moments.
I won't ask you to describe them
now and I won't share mine with you,
but if we think about Karaoke,
we know that it elicit
something pretty strong in us.
And so researchers have taken hold of
this idea and actually brought karaoke
sets into the lab, right? These
are some of the most, you know,
Rad labs you can think of in the world
where they try to use this tool to elicit
and understand self conscious
emotions like embarrassment.
So what you have people do is you use
a well validated tacit goes as follows.
So people come into the lab and they're
asked to remain seated quietly while you
acquire a resting baseline.
Sort of getting what their current
emotional state is that day in the lab.
Next you tell them,
okay,
well we're going to do is have you
participate in this study where we look at
your emotional responses to singing.
And in my lab we've used
this task using the song,
which is a favorite of mine is
the Beatles Song Twist and shout.
And while participants are singing along
with this song wearing headphones, um,
they're being videotaped
unbeknownst to them later on,
after completing a series of unrelated lab
tasks, Bam, up on the computer monitor,
they get to watch this
video of themselves.
The best part of it though is
that there is no background music.
So literally all they're hearing is
their own voice. Sing along to the song.
And as you can see here,
this is the period of the study that
we know reliably elicits the emotion of
embarrassment.
And at the end we have people self
report their emotional experience,
not only how embarrassed they feel,
but how positive in general and how
negative in general did they feel.
So I'll show you an example of one of
my colleagues here at Yale University,
Laurie Santos, participating
in this study. So again,
she was asked to sing along to
the Beatle Song, twist and shout.
Well,
okay,
come on mom. Mom. Mom Pay man. Come on.
Well yeah, no,
you look so good.
Yeah,
yeah. You've got make Darwin. Nah,
just like I knew you would.
Well I'll shake it up a
statue.
Come on baby
God on and work it all out.
Yeah,
we had twisted a little
girl. Yeah, no, yeah.
Twice a fun. Yeah, no,
not twist a little closer.
Now I know that you're mad.
And another
video that I'm very excited to share
with you of one of our most favorite
laboratory participants
completing this task is John Lutz,
who's a television writer who's written
for both Saturday night live and 30 rock.
And you may know him as playing
the character. Let's on 30 rock.
So now I'm very excited to show
you a video of John Lutz. Indeed,
even as you know, a
famous writer, an actor,
he too experienced embarrassment when
having to sing the song, twist and shout,
and then have the video of
himself presented back to him.
So in summary,
when we think of music and singing
as a tool for eliciting emotion,
we see that it's very good at eliciting
emotional processes like reactivity.
And the advantages are that it's
relatively simple, effective.
And as you saw by some of the
video demonstrations engaging.
The disadvantages though
can be that for one,
when you use music to elicit emotions,
it's really difficult to match the
musical tastes to the participant.
So I sewed you Eric,
I x technique of using classical music,
which doesn't fit everyone,
right?
So you want to try your
best to standardize music,
but also match it to the
people who come into the lab.
And as you saw in some of the videos,
um, by both Laura Santos and John,
let's from 30 rock and
Saturday night live,
there can be some part of Smith discomfort
when you ask them to sing in front of
the camera and then
present it back to them.
So now we're gonna move on to
the acoustic startle reflex.
So that startle reflex has three parts.
And this is something that we all are
ingrained with and built with us human
beings. So first, if we hear
some stimulus, some loud,
just Bam noise in front of us,
we have an initial response and
this occurs within 500 milliseconds.
And it consists of a stereotype
pattern of sematic and muscular actions
associated with physiological responding.
So we all just kind of shutter jolt,
right? This is something we all do. Now,
the part that's relevant for emotion
researchers is what comes, comes after,
which is a secondary emotional response.
So essentially what you're getting is
a person's emotional response to having
been startled.
And this varies widely across individuals.
It can take place in
the form of amusement,
sort of laughing at yourself for
having been startled, embarrassment,
and even anger or fear.
So Acoustic startle reflex as a
methodology is really good at eliciting
reactivity as you saw across
the wide variety of emotions.
It has the advantage of being
relatively simple, unobtrusive,
and you can get these both
automatic primary responses
as well as more secondary
emotion responses to having been startled.
The disadvantages though,
or is that it's often limited to measuring
just the general defensive kind of
reflects of response.
So you can't really tap into more
specific emotions very easily.
So you can use it for
some kinds of responses,
but you can't use it to measure the
whole wide variety of our emotional,
you know,
repertoire.
So we'll move from acoustic startle
reflex to what's called startle eyeblink
modulation.
And I'll explain what this means now.
So startle eyeblink modulation is
a really interesting phenomena.
So essentially what you're measuring is
how big of an eye blink did you make?
Right? It was at a very big, I
blink or really tiny. I blink.
And you may wonder how the heck is
that relevant to emotion at all?
I certainly remember thinking the
same thing when I joined the lab as an
Undergrad student and they were having
me code the magnitude of how big a
person's blink was.
But what's really cool about
startle eyeblink modulation
is it actually can tell
us a wide variety about emotion
that's less susceptible to demand
characteristics or people trying to guess
what the experiment is about or rate
what they think they ought
to be feeling in that study.
So what we do with startle eyeblink
modulation is you attach a variety of
electrodes to the person's face,
and these electrodes can be used to
measure the amplitude or how big the eye
blink is. Now, this may seem
pretty wild to you at first sight,
but larger eye blinks are an indirect
indicator of negative emotions,
whereas smaller eye blinks are an
indirect indicator of positive emotions.
So I was like this analogy
that helps illustrate this.
So imagine you're walking down a dark
alley and something startles you, right?
You're likely to have a
very big reflexive response,
including a very big eye blink.
So that's because you were probably
anxious or a little nervous.
So in a way your eye blink
actually provided a window
into how you were feeling.
Now contrast this with walking down a
sunny beach, right? It's a sunny day.
The skies are clear and
again, out of nowhere someone
comes out and startles you.
Now you're going to still blink,
but how big you blink is actually going
to be attenuated or it's going to be a
smaller eye blink.
So what you're really getting at is
how much people respond to startles.
So while people are
wearing these electrodes,
you present a brief noise over there,
headphones that causes them to blink and
whether they blink of a large magnitude
or small magnitude in response
to watching a series of prompts.
I apps photos that we talked about
in our last lecture positively,
negatively or neutrally balanced or
watching emotional films actually highly
correlates with people self
reported emotion experience,
but does it in a way that's more indirect
in a way that some people might say is
an actually more reliable
indicator of their emotion state.
So the eye and perhaps the eye blink can
be a window into a person's emotional
soul,
surprisingly enough.
So when we think about
Acoustic startle reflex,
what we're getting at our
processes and emotional reactivity,
how much your eyes quote blink in response
to feeling negative or positive when
startled.
The advantages are that it's simple,
unobtrusive and less subject to demand
characteristics as we just spoke about.
But the disadvantages are you really
only get broadly at positive and negative
leave valence behaviors.
You can't really get into complex emotions
like pride or embarrassment or shame.
So you have a less rich Rhett
repertoire of emotional behavior.
But if your question is really focused
on how positive or how negative is that
person feeling in the moment, it can be
a useful tool for that specific purpose.
So now I want to turn to our final
tool in our emotional toolbox,
which is the directed facial action task.
So this is a really cool task and one of
the first that was used in the field of
emotional dissertation.
So for the directed facial action task,
I'm going to ask you to
engage in an exercise with me.
What I'd like you to do is to first
get out a sheet of paper and a pen.
So now you're sitting at your
laptop watching this video.
So I'd like you to just for a second,
kind of go old school and go get out
an actual piece of paper and a pen.
And then I'm going to ask you to follow
some instructions along with me. Okay.
So let's assume you now have a piece of
paper and a pen and I want you to do the
following. Okay? So take one
I'd like you to do is pull the
corners of your mouth downward.
Now as the corners of
your mouth stay downward,
raise your eyebrows up
and pull them together.
Kind of bring them towards
the center of your face.
Now squint your eyes slightly as
you're doing all these things.
Okay?
And hold this for 10
seconds. So one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight,
nine and 10.
Now I'd like you to write down
how do you feel this was take one.
So very negative over here at the left,
negative four to zero,
which is neutral to positive is four.
So pick one of these numbers here
right now to indicate how you feel.
Okay?
Now we're going to do take two.
So follow my instructions again.
This time I want you to pull your eyebrows
together towards the center of your
face,
okay?
Why didn't your eyes by
pooling your upper eyelid ups?
So kind of try to get your eyes big,
pull up your eyelid,
get those eyes nice and big.
Press your lips together.
Hold him really tight.
And as you have your eyebrows together,
your eyes are widened,
your lips are pressed. Try to
tighten your lips and raise them up.
Now hold this for 10 seconds and
we'll count together. So one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine and 10. Okay.
Now I'd like you to rate how you
feel now. Negative four, negative,
zero, neutral, all the
way up to four positive.
And now take three. And thanks for bearing
with me. So let's try this together.
Pull the corners of your
mouth upward this time.
Okay,
now take the corners of your mouth
as they're up and pull them outwards.
So away from the center of your
face as much as you possibly can.
Squint your eyes slightly
and hold this for 10 seconds.
All right, so let's count
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine and 10.
Okay,
so write down how you feel
negative four all the way up to four.
And let's try to guess.
So for take one,
this was the facial configuration
that's associated with sadness.
So most people report feeling more on
the negative spectrum of that scale you
saw on the negative number range.
So these are the facial muscles,
the muscles associated with sadness.
And we find that when people sort of
basically put their faces in the muscle
configurations that are associated
with the display of sadness,
we actually report feeling
more negative or more sad.
What would you guess for take two?
What kinds of emotions did you feel?
Well you were correct for the day and can
get extra credit if you guessed anger.
So again,
you probably should've seen that your
emotions were being rated as more negative
as well here. Now finally for take three,
what would be your guests? What do you,
what kind of emotions did you
experience and rate? Well, here you go.
What we had you do is put your face in
the configuration that's associated with
feeling joy and happiness.
And we find that when people do that,
either through the
instructions I gave you,
or even simply by at being asked to put
a pen and hold it here on their lip,
that we find that people
actually report feeling happy.
So there's some sort of feedback loop
between the muscles in your face signaling
and emotion state to your brain that
then in turn actually helps engender the
emotion experience itself.
So people will say this expression
like turn that frown upside down.
Well to some extent there's truth to that.
If we actually try to make our faces,
you know,
show an expression of joy or happiness,
we may actually in turn subjectively
feel more positive and happy.
So you can do this task both explicitly.
The way we did it today in class,
instructing people to move
facial muscles in the take one,
two and three we just went through,
or like I was indicating
with the pen implicitly.
So just ask people to move their facial
muscles for what seems to be a seemingly
unrelated or different tasks.
So holding a pen on their lip or putting
a pen in their mouth said sort of
elicit the kinds of muscles involved in
happiness display because you can see it
causes the corners of her mouth to go up,
for example.
And for some people it might even cause
this sort of a raising of the cheeks or
crows eyes, the squinting that's also
associated with a Duchenne smile,
which is an indicator of happiness
we'll talk about later in the course.
Okay,
so summary here.
So the processes,
you can list it with the directed
facial action task or reactivity.
You can get people to feel emotions.
It's also as in terms of its advantages,
simple, unobtrusive and less
subject to demand characteristics.
But the disadvantages are you can't really
assess reactivity to external stimuli.
What you are able to assess is how
much people respond when their face has
changed, the muscle configurations that
are associated with prototypical emotion
displays,
but you can't get sort of how they're
responding to events occurring in the
world around them,
either on the computer screen or
when interacting with another person.
Yeah.
So we've gone through eight broad
domains of tools and methods. Um,
the latter for we touched on today.
So now I'd like to move
to our takeaway questions.
Yeah.
The first question asks,
well,
what were the four emotional
dissertation tools covered today, Aka,
or are you paying attention when we
went through the lecture today? Second,
which of the three key emotional
processes, so reactivity, regulation,
and understanding did each of the two
four tools discussed today? Target.
And finally,
what were the strengths and limitations
of each of the four tools discussed
today?
And with that,
we'll turn to a wonderful expert
interview in the domain of emotional
elicitation and measurement.
And again,
this is part of our experts
in emotion interview series.
Today we'll be speaking with doctor
Gregg Siegal on emotion elicitation.
Dr Siegel received his PhD degrees
from the San Diego State University and
University of California San Diego joint
doctoral program in clinical psychology.
He also completed a clinical internship
at the center for addiction and mental
health in Toronto and an NIH postdoctoral
fellowship in clinical cognitive
neuroscience at the Western
psychiatric institute and Clinic.
He's currently an associate professor
of psychiatry at the University of
Pittsburgh School of Medicine,
where he directs the program and
cognitive aspect of neuroscience.
Doctor Siegel's research program
examines brain mechanisms of depression,
anxiety,
and recovery from these conditions,
as well as using tools of neuroscience
to predict responses to treatments and
guide novel Treatment Development.
Dr Siegel has authored over 90
publications and 13 book chapters and has
received several honors,
including the Western
psychiatric institute and
Clinic Young Investigator Award
and the junior faculty scholar award.
So I now turn to a special experts and
emotion interview with Doctor Gregg Segal.